doch wir den präsentiert von rogers
[Musik]
abstimmungssonntag in bern mitglieder
mehrere komitees gegen die nobel ag
negative haben sich versammelt um
gemeinsam das resultat dieser
denkwürdigen abstimmung zu erfahren
hochachtung für mobile initiativen und
deckt original trend bestätigt auch
wieder hoch
es herrscht klarheit endlich und das
resultat ist deutlich über 71 prozent
der abstimmenden lehnen die radikale
initiative welche den medialen service
publique die gebühren streichen wollte
doch alle wissen hier
die abstimmung ist nur eine
zwischenetappe in einer hitzigen debatte
die andauern wird
denn die kritik hat nach konsumieren die
schweiz hat man eher fritz lang versucht
die bastion es sein die heimische
größten unmut entstanden und und der
unmut wird jetzt eine initiative
lanciert
[Musik]
srf ein unternehmen der srg
seit im november 2017 bekannt wurde dass
die sogenannte no bielak initiative im
märz zur abstimmung kommt hagelt es noch
mehr kritik in südkorea verheerend die
lücke im rallye sport
der kundendienst nimmt auch lob fürs
programm
aber die bevorstehende abstimmung wirkt
sie ein beschleuniger für wutbürger und
unzufriedene
tagesschau nicht wie lag würdig es ist
eine schande wie gesprochen wird
wir leben bestens ohne tv ihr seid echt
kranke bastards
also bitte herr letzte abstimmung sarina
zum beispiel ist die zeit genau masse
wurde vor bei einer partei von der
gartner unter befürworter 1 prozent
wurde ina muhß der werbe kümmert und die
sind essentiell für dieses programms
esther maurer rahmenprogramm im abstrich
machen
entweder ist man rasiert oder hat einen
bart unrasiert was soll das wundert euch
nicht wenn die no bielak initiative
angenommen
grund sagt gestern nach immer nur die
gleiche aber was man einfach merkt ist
dass die abstimmung nicht präsent ist
dass jeder zuschauer wieder höre ist
eine rückhaltung die abstimmung am 1
und was gehört wieder das kosovo ich
liebe es stimme aber ich wünsche mir das
und das machen bis zu gut wo die usa und
andere kritik kam aus ihren die
moderatoren oder am programm gibt es
seit es fernsehen und radio gibt auch
die kritik an der angeblich linken
gesinnung der srg hat tradition
[Musik]
das ist dass kommunisten schweizer
fernsehen will brauchen keine gelenkte
demokratie meine damen und herren alle
arena ein generaldirektor der das svp
partei wird ist doch eigentlich
undenkbar
die kritik von rechts geht auf ihn
zurück walter hofer svp nationalrat und
historiker 1974 gründete er den
sogenannten hofer club 80 prozent vor
der tagesschau redaktion herzlich zum
sozialismus in allen seinen farben
bekannt dass ist das ist doch einfach
und tolerantes nicht wie das radio und
das fernsehen wo der puristische
gesellschaft einigermaßen entspricht
neben ihr würde bestätigen
es war schlimm stellte politik sei es
hat das match praktisch proporz
redaktion erhöht sein
das könnte dazu führen dass man ungefähr
die größten jetzt kein vor ohne sie
würde den versorger und da sei doch wohl
gott vor
[Musik]
1995 trat der damalige jungliberale
gregor ott dem hofer club bei 2008
folgte auf den hofer club die aktion
medienfreiheit an der spitze die svp
nationalräte gregor rutz und natalie
rickli bis ende 2017 war sie managerin
der werbe vermarktungsfirma goldbach
group
rickli und rutz das gespann der svp für
medienpolitik natalie rickli wollte
schon 2009 die radio und fernsehgebühren
halbieren
140000 mal wurde ihre petition
unterschrieben
rickli und rutz lancierten seit 2009 im
parlament rund 30 srg kritische vorstöße
[Musik]
mit dieser geballten kritik muss er
umgehen vilma schon seit letztem herbst
ist der roma srg generaldirektor das
größte medienhaus der schweiz steht
unter druck wie nie zuvor
es ist eine beispiellose krisensituation
den letzten sechs monate waren sehr
schwierig ich habe genau gewusst worauf
ich mich einlasse
aber ich bin dem service publique so
verbunden dass ich mich ohne wenn und
aber engagieren
diese sache ist wichtiger als meine
persönliche befindlichkeit
das sind marshalls gegner 2016 haben sie
ihre initiative eingereicht
für den medienwissenschaftler matthias
künstler kam die initiative nicht
überraschend ein initiativtext
formulieren ein paar meter werden comics
ist dann sehen dass die frösche
verbindung zwischen verbraten vesper
jungliberalen freisinnige und libertär
energie hat es freut mich besonders
einige grundsätzliche gedanken zum thema
familienpolitik mit vier rbis der
libertäre ökonom würde den sozialstaat
am liebsten abschaffen
er ist ein verbündeter der srg kritiker
gmbh sitzt neben gregor rutz ebenfalls
im vorstand der aktion medienfreiheit
bisher ist direktor des liberalen
instituts 1 fink der den staat auf ein
minimum zurückfahren will
insider sagen christoph blocher habe dem
institut über die jahre rund 300000
franken zukommen lassen
auf anfrage meint blocher dass zwei
möglich er wisse es nicht mehr mit den
libertären sei im geist verbunden
auch die svp will die aufgaben des
staates minimieren
doch so weit wie die libertären geht sie
nicht besser würde den staat am liebsten
auf justiz polizei und militär
beschränken vize-direktor des liberalen
instituts ist olivier kessler der
architekt der nobilia initiative an
seiner seite
mitstreiter florian mayer ein
schwachsinniger zu hause beim 29
jährigen florian mayer dem
generalsekretär des mobile kernteams er
wohnt bei seinen eltern
historisch ist auch marco polo de gaulle
herrscht in china was soll ich
informiere mich über zig oder so stimmt
die soziale medien jetzt im moment bin
ich ihr politisch sehr engagiert sind
und muss ich ja hier emissionen aber
vorhaben ich tue auch in china kommt und
sie haben das sehr gut
juni im schweizer fernsehen bleibt
florian mayer ist einer von drei
jungfreisinnigen die vor bald fünf
jahren bei
runde bier auf die idee kamen die radio
und fernsehgebühren abzuschaffen
ihr credo nur dafür zahlen was man
tatsächlich auch konsumiert seinen
master in business administration hat er
in peking gemacht zurück in der schweiz
kämpft er nun vollamtlich für weniger
staat und mehr marktwirtschaft das
gesundheitssystem krankenkassen
anbelangt so stattlich sie wichtig nicht
so viele vorschriften gestoppt ist immer
sehr hoch bleibt außer ist es sicher
sinnvoll twitter zu machen
das ist jedes ziel ist die drastische
modus zählen und tyson gay ist erste
ziel auf dem werk geschlossen weil
florian meyer erhält besuch von anna
schweiz ebenfalls mitglied im nobilia
initiativkomitee die beiden analysieren
den gegenwärtigen stand ihres kampfes
gegen den medialen service.de blick so
gut wie ich dass bene nutzer selbst ich
muss ehrlich sagen
zudem stamme also das problem für mich
wenn ich dadurch nicht brannte für mich
sollte ich würde sagen dass wir draußen
sondern konsumieren und der
solidaritätsgedanke hat dasselbe sagen
ich zahle nicht für gemeinschaft das
andere kind konsumieren ich finde die
medienbereiche volker staab medien sind
nicht weiß wo man muss aber solidarität
ist jetzt solidarität wird definiert
finanzieren auf diesem grundsatz für
unsere gesellschaft aufgebaut ist der
leistungsausgleich zum beispiel oder
eine solidarische finanzierung all diese
ideen sind in einer digitalen
gesellschaft grundsätzlich in frage
gestellt
das betrifft den ganzen service publique
alle öffentlichen dienstleistungen im
zuge der digitalisierung stehen neue
ideen im raum wie zum beispiel jeder
soll sein leben selber individuell
meistern ohne sich frage zu müssen was
das wir alle anderen heißt und was das
für die gesellschaft als ganzes bedeutet
da stecken wir in einer zwickmühle
wir müssen immer wieder erklären dass es
in einem land wie unserem gemeinsame
werte gibt diese werte lassen sich nicht
einfach in geld umwandeln oder kaufen
man kann sie nicht einfach aufteilen
gilles marchand trat sein neues amt in
einer schwierigen zeit an wenige wochen
bevor die abstimmungs debatte fahrt
aufnahm
nach seiner wahl ist er von genf nach
bern gezogen
er habe mit dem neuen job seine
komfortzone verlassen sagt er
nun ist er pausenlos unterwegs pendelt
zwischen allen landesteilen und stellt
unterschiede fest in der romandie ist
die legitimation des staates größere man
akzeptiert dass wir das zusammenleben
organisieren
gewiss man kritisierte man ärgert sich
über ihn aber grundsätzlich findet man
erst richtig in der deutschschweiz
beobachte ich dass das verhältnis zum
staat anders ist er freiwillige art der
staat ist schon okay aber wenn man ihn
umgehen kann warum nicht
und so kommt es dass diese ideen die
eigenverantwortung der individualität
stärker vorhanden sind als in der
romandie
noch nie stand die srg so in der kritik
ein generaldirektor derart unter druck
deshalb sucht der neue srg chef den
dialog hierbei wird er an einer tagung
der werbebranche in genf auftritte in
der romandie sind für ihn ein heimspiel
warschau ist zu gast in der sendung afra
road in london zur arena von srf diese
kakophonie der unrealistischen vorschlag
gezeigt dass es wahnsinnig kompliziert
ist und das gleichgewicht in der schweiz
sehr fragil hotel schweizerhof noch zwei
monate bis zur abstimmung
gilles marchand ist gast in einem
prominent besetzten streitgespräch zum
ersten mal muss er sich hier in einer
fremdsprache auf deutsch an seiner seite
bundesrätin und medienministerin doris
leuthard sie diskutieren mit den no
bielak befürwortern olivier kessler und
svp nationalrat lukas reimann meine
frage natürlich haben sie was leistet
zuerst möchte ich mich entschuldigen
mein deutsch ist nicht perfekt wie sie
können irren aber am besten zum meine
argumente hinzuzugewinnen
was leicht was dir sage die es ag gehört
zu den menschen gehen menschen gerne
schweizer und wir probieren eine gute
vollprogramm zu bieten weil wir glauben
dass es ist natürlich für unser wir
gefühl in der schweiz das ist unser
hauptauftrag meine mutter war nicht
dasselbe fans ich früher an die ich und
meine enkel noch was anderes und in
dieser breite müssen wird auch für
unsere bevölkerung was präsentieren und
nicht sagen jeder bezahlt nur dass ihm
gerade passt schon
es gibt es kein problem es gibt ein blow
elvis' liquidationen das ist so wie die
liquidation wie liegt ja ich hab's nicht
gehört was sagen sie wenn sie noch
keinen plan b aus gearbeitet haben sind
sie dann in ihrem büro nicht besser
aufgehoben das jetzt auch zu entwickeln
aus durch die ganze schweiz zu tun um
den leuten panik zu machen und zu sagen
es gäbe uns dann auch nicht mehr
ok grundsätzlich und ich spüre eine gute
stube sagen was mich enttäuscht hat dass
der schöne morgen schon die general
gedacht oder essen kray konkret ist die
neue hatte in einer mit komplettservice
der fünfte akt werde wieder vertröstet
und was ich denn nach der abstimmung
noch mit alles gut im jahr mehr
interaktion klar aber konkret wird man
etwas langsam ihren vormarsch erhält an
diesem abend nicht zum ersten mal dass
die srg abspecken müssen kaum platz
lasse für private konkurrenten
die ursachen für diese vorwürfe liegen
in der vergangenheit
damals entschied die politik die srg vor
der ausländischen konkurrenz zu schützen
[Musik]
dieser
die srg damals stark und unbestritten
man hat anfangs carrier für baustein
privatsache des egf bauen wo die anderen
länder wo eigentlich die marktgröße wird
sein wie ist das gelungen also bis wie
es im flämischen teil farbige oder
beispielsweise irland hat die politik
hat das eigentlich mit unterstützt
[Musik]
der schweizer heimatschutz gewählt und
das heißt man hat sich auf sprache ich
unter allen nationalen ebene paetzel
hauptsächlich nur mit tessa getätigt
dass die spd mit der ausländischen
privaten der komet alte mit konkurrieren
damals war adolf ogi medienminister
neben ihm rainer keller in jenen jahren
vize direktor im bundesamt für
kommunikation
keller schrieb die grundlagen für ein
gesetz das die vormachtstellung der srg
zementierte schwierige frage 1993
entstand dann doch eine art konkurrenz
aber es war eine srg interne konkurrenz
[Musik]
auf wiedersehen hockenheim war direktor
von es bloss einem zweiten deutsch
schweizer kanal innerhalb der srg ein
kleiner schritt für uns herr
bundespräsident ein großer für die
schweizer medienszene machen wir das
über die sage dass man innerhalb von
rasse geht seit der konkurrenz schärfer
das ist mehr als gewagt oder also martin
haupt von der firma als konkurrenz sich
der etablierte zwischen 2 1 eigentlich
zweimal schon vermögend
nach nur anderthalb jahren war es bloß
am ende
[Gelächter]
es folgte ein zweiter versuch einer
hauseigenen srg konkurrenz schweiz 4
auch dieser versuch scheiterte es plus
und schweiz 4
rund 180 millionen franken verlorene
gebührengelder wider besseren wissens
aus dass ich irgendwo r eine politische
wunschkatalog sich oder das ist erste
private fernseh- foto schweiz
[Musik]
der elfjährige traums tv3 schweizer
fernsehen wie noch nie
ende der 1990 er jahre entstanden doch
noch zwei private nationale
fernsehsender als konkurrenz zur srg tv3
und tele 24
aber sie überlebten nur zwei respektive
drei jahre
vermutlich ist das sport sie will an die
neunziger jahre ist es neues phänomen uv
licht aus meschwitz erwerb ich auf
ausländische fahrzeuge zum beispiel
fährt oder sat1 pro7 schaltet und damit
sind die schweizerische privat viel
härtere wettbewerb ausgesetzt aber ob es
wirklich die privaten daran gehindert
sich zu entwickeln
ich weiß nicht als sie in den 90er
jahren die werbefenster aufkamen hatte
man die idee dass das geldhaus dieser
werbung im schweizer inhalte und
programme investiert werden sollen das
ging vielleicht zwei oder drei jahre so
aus dem programm hat man sich dann
wieder zurückgezogen
die werbung aber berg das ist die auch
rentabel
das ist extrem schwierig in einem so
kleinen gebiet aufgeteilt in
verschiedene sprachen ein rentables tv
programm zu machen
zu beginn des neuen jahrtausends blieb
nur die srg übrig als starker und
selbstbewusster marktleader eine s ag
die jetzt in frage gestellt ist
drei männer
nun schreit sowie noch der wunsch muss
freie wähler will kann dies mehr als
verstaubte vor zwei jahren noch qualität
und die betrag ist windig vor der bilder
ist völlig bezeichnete journalismus und
wissenschaft habe noch nie
du musst vielleicht den erfolg sagte
wenn du sag jetzt mal an du es sollte
für die nacht sollen eine pauschale
gebühr oder onlinefamily machen also ich
glaube ich muss ich kein visum mehr
darum mitten im einkaufs getümmel
treffen die initianten zufällig auf die
zürcher sp nationalrätin jacqueline
badran
[Gelächter]
überhaupt mit den geköpften am schluss
auch der zürcher svp-nationalrat mauro
tuena ist an diesem tag auf einkaufstour
und den etat unterliegen natürlich im
bereich foto brise ja was liegt
offiziell noch nicht vor
[Musik]
florian mayer ist mit seiner mitstreiter
christian riesen auf dem weg ins
schweizer fernsehen sie wollen gemeinsam
die aufzeichnung der arena sendung
schauen
zur selben zeit die teilnehmer der
diskussion zur nobile initiative sind
auf dem weg ins arena studio olivier
kessler sorgt sich um die ausgewogenheit
erfordert das nicht der moderator
sondern ein mobiler befürworter
bundesrätin doris leuthard interview
konzept das sind schon alles sehr wohl
fraglich kritische publikum stellen wenn
sie jetzt wieder
denn wird das miteinander
akzeptieren ich brauche so genannte
selbst noch florian mayer verfolgt die
aufzeichnung in der fernseh kantine vom
wirrwarr hinter den kulissen hat er
nichts mitbekommen
die argumente zugunsten der
gebührengelder kann er nicht
nachvollziehen
heute erhalten neben der srg 34 private
radio und tv stationen gebührengelder
der großteil der gelder in das vlies zur
srg sie betreibt damit 24 radio und tv
sender in vier sprachregionen
[Musik]
wille sich iris oberste unternehmerische
ziel aus generaldirektor
ich will die stelle von der srg
wohin geht der dax ohne auf der
musikverein dreis von schweizer radio
drs eis führen swiss kultur und jazz den
sender von liebhabern für liebhaber
[Musik]
die ära walpen sie dauerte 14 jahre und
brachte elf neue radio und fernsehsender
hervor
gespiesen durch höhere gebühren und
genehmigt durch den bundesrat
zehn prozent mehr gebühren hat die srg
antrag daraus wird nun nichts
der bundesrat marion fernsehen zur
bescheidenheit 5,3 prozent mehr müssten
reichen
man muss sich das so vorstellen oder da
gibt es 70 da kommt ein corona von
dresser geht und den hätten squillaci
wenn wir jetzt nicht mindestens stars zu
versprechen
sicher wird sein dass wir vorhaben die
wir verwirklichen wollte wahrscheinlich
nicht machen können ein halbes jahr
später lanciert die srg ein neues
jugendradio wie muss ich scharf sandig
das morgen schon mit dem weg dass ich
jetzt nicht gott alle waldsee und das
haben wir nichts ärgert und das hat ihre
sache teilt mir natürlich noch ein
anderer ort die finanzen freigespielt
beantragt waren 6,5 prozent gebühren
erhöhung der bundesrat genehmigt nur 2,5
prozent
die esta geht möchte ihr programm ja
massiv ausbauen
natürlich hätten wir eine etwas höhere
gebührenanpassungen gewünschten aber wir
haben darauf zu achten dass sie ihren
gesetzlichen auftrag erfüllen kann und
sind überzeugt sie kann es auch so
das unternehmen steckt mit 80 millionen
franken im minus der haben probleme bei
der werbung der und irgendwann genügt
auch bei dresser geht das geld nicht
mehr das sind erhebliche sitzige hat mit
einem rush rules greifen sondern schluss
bedingungen das wäre natürlich ihre
position mit all dem balkan christopher
ticket das ist normal weil ich das nie
gemacht hatte hatte ich mir vier liter
vorwurf machen als ich grüße die gesetze
hielten 18 programm nein gar nicht
derzeit sind elf neue programm und
sandra entstand ja aber in vier
sprachregionen armin walpen galt als
begnadeter lobbyist stets für eine
starke srg im jahr 2004 notierte die srg
dagegen dass private regionale tv-sender
gelder aus dem gebührentopf erhalten
sollen an walpen seite cvp
parteikollegen norbert hochreutener
vormals journalist
leichtathletik
hoffentlich sind
so beschreiben wenn jetzt einen antrag
gemacht aber mit zusammen mit dem
bacchus kauften das wird gegrüßt hat was
das für den alltag ist mir noch zu
anderen bundesräten mittwoch setzte
gegangen reparieren den die interveniere
zugunsten den herrn dass die anderen
bundesländer ja das gibt's doch gezwickt
und hand aus nachher hinter sich hat ja
also ich geb's zu halten ich bin mir
vorstelle gut aber so ganz mit bewirkt
wunder dass die besteht mich jetzt nicht
im interesse ist vor der us ag oder die
möglichkeit mit anderen bundesrat
darüber zu reden und seine dort lecker
war oben
dass das millimeter von der srg ist
nichts negatives
danach stand da hat es großes misstrauen
gegen muller machte größten ist der neue
generaldirektor relativiert das bild der
zu großen s ag wenn man uns innerhalb
der schweiz vergleicht dann ist die srg
sehr groß und stark
vergleicht man uns hingegen mit der
ausländischen konkurrenz
dann ist die srg ziemlich klein seine
ausländischen kollegen haben mir noch
nie gesagt dass die srg arrogant sei im
gegenteil in frankreich deutschland oder
italien empfindet man unseren service
publique als bescheiden klug und klein
armin walpen stärkte zwar die srg aber
die öffentliche kritik am unternehmen
und an seiner person wurde größer ist
[Musik]
als 2005 publik wurde dass armin walpen
als dienstwagen einen porsche cayenne
vor entwickelte sich daraus ein
kommunikatives fiasko erst behauptete
die srg den porsche habe armin walpen
mit seinem lohn gekauft dann hieß es
alles ganz anders
die srg stelle den porsche zur verfügung
respektive einen dienstwagen mit
chauffeur im wert von 75.000 franken den
walpen auch privat nutzen können
rainer keller erinnert sich mit dem
rücken zur wand standen dass at&t
transparenz gemangelt hat möglichst
billiger das top-management gar aufsicht
und operatives geschäft ist nicht gut
trennt sie und es ist immer mehr kritik
dass es an transparenz
damals war man sich bei der srg keiner
fehler bewusst
einzig richtige sowohl gewichtet in ihre
innere privilegierte sehr privilegierte
situation natürlich sogar für gäste
blieben hier findet man das wirklich ein
hormon und koran wir machen gute zogen
hans mitterer mit her mit den gebühren
die zeiten haben sich geändert
gilles marchand will für transparenz ein
stehen
ausgegossen zu den leistungen der mir
zustehen würden gehört auch ein
dienstwagen
ich habe keinen weil ich momentan
brauche ich beziehe keinen lohn der
öffentlich ist ein variabler
lohnbestandteil hängt von dem ergebnis
gegenüber dem verwaltungsrat lediglich
rechenschaft haben und wir werden vom
bakom kontrolliert ganz ehrlich ich habe
nicht den eindruck dass wir uns selbst
überlassen sind und vor uns hin was drin
können wir machen alles so professionell
und korrekt wie möglich
sema show war 15 jahre lang direktor des
westschweizer fernsehens rts und
mitglied der sed geschäftsleitung unter
seiner leitung muss sich die srg mehr
denn je verändern
es gibt im deutschen das schöne wort
halten
wir müssen uns fragen haben wir die
passende haltung haben mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter egal auf welcher stufe
manchmal den eindruck dass alles gegeben
ist
während jahre waren wir die einzigen die
wussten wie es geht dem ist nicht mehr
so hat sich unser verhalten diesen
veränderungen angepasst
heute kann jeder produzieren das
publikum stellt selber inhalte her
wir haben nicht mehr die hoheit über das
know how das ist psychologisch gesehen
gar nicht so einfach
die position rechtfertigt heute nichts
mehr
es ist einzig die kompetenz die zählt
das heißt auch im richtigen moment am
richtigen ort mit dem passenden mitteln
zu sein
wenn sie das schaffen haben sie recht
wenn nicht liegen sie falsch
egal wer sie sind jährlich werden über
30.000 besucher durch die zürcher
studios des schweizer fernsehens geführt
und in den letzten monaten ist das
interesse nochmals gewachsen
heute ist es eine gruppe studierende der
uni zürich alle mehrjährigen sind 100%
betrieb tätig ich sage bis 2.30 uhr
führt abteilung unterhaltung im moment
alles vorzimmer brauchen vom
unterhaltungschef
das fernseh studio leutschenbach
zusammengehalten durch unzählige lange
gänge
es zählt 13 studios hier arbeiten 2000
leute ein wenig charmanter
zusammengewürfelter gebäudekomplex und
die körperlich denkt man oft in medias
res zum jonas ball nicht stoppen
aufgebot für das war bevor ri geliefert
anders aber diese stoffe und dort sachen
liebe frieden
wie verbringt es ist klar es macht hier
total spaß ein super moderator alle
leute sind beteiligt ist immer sendung
die alle leute beschäftigen
das würde sich doch sofort privat
finanzieren ich bin heute wofür sondern
auch arbeiten und ich bin sicher nicht
der oder politisch position bezieht
inwiefern bis mit oder ohne gebühren
finanzierbar ist
aber ich kann sagen dass wenn ich muss
abwägen zwischen quote und inhalt
nämlich immer der inhalt des
verpflichtet jede abstiegs an dick
machen die obst kurs der vorlage wo kann
manche interessiert mache mir da es an
die genau wie wieandt
all das ist ne biscotte maximiert ist
natürlich wurde werbe franken wird
maximieren ziel der führungen den leuten
ein erlebnis bieten und ihnen erklären
was die srg leistet
mehr handball sport panorama mein sport
aktuell bäume und wenn sie jetzt danke
jetzt aber noch gar nie dass ich heute
sage ohne licht erschien war vor oder
haben sie recht hingegen die können mir
wohnte brachte können wir die berichte
während vorne hufe led-lampe glitzer wo
funkel und denke nachdem das war früher
anders fernsehen war an und für sich
schon ein ereignis
[Musik]
1966 zum beispiel als das schweizer
fernsehen das fußball wm spiel schweiz
gegen deutschland übertrug die nation
versammelte sich vor den wenigen
fernsehgeräten
das publikum wurde live zeuge dass die
schweiz 0 zu 5 verlor auch das schweizer
radio damals beliebt unbestritten
konkurrenzlos ein medium für nachrichten
und emotionen
weltweit ist die ausstrahlung des
schweizerischen kurzwellensender der zur
aufgabe hat beim auslandschweizer und
dem ausländischen hörer die schweiz nahe
zu bringen
in der nacht wenn alle an den sender
ruhen ist man im neuen gebäude der
schweizerischen radio und
fernsehgesellschaft in bergen an der
arbeit wenn vermehren australien oder
neuseeland wird ein schweizer seefahrer
den gruß seiner mutter aus bern
empfangen
zum schluss besucht die gruppe das
tagesschau studio für moderator florian
inhauser sind es besondere zeiten diese
monate des abstimmungskampfs er und sein
team müssen immer wieder über die noble
initiative berichten
es ist nicht mal so sehr an der
stimmrechte weder über das anders wenn
ich also tatsächlich und das gilt ja für
meine kolleginnen und kollegen
tragischen anderen audi dieses
geborgenheit und von der neutralität und
objektivität das gebot gilt immer
natürlich im hinterkopf macht man sich
den andere gedanke als als als spinnerei
in ihrer vorlage wo das leben gewählt
aber dass sich dass der stoff kavala
merkel das wäre verheerend
[Applaus]
auch hier werden täglich tv news
produziert mit einem bruchteil des
budgets der tagesschau nok duftes uhr
ein tag vor dem großen sport oder i fügt
redaktionssitzung bei telezüri mit 70
mitarbeitenden ist es der größte private
regionalsender der schweiz finanziert
ohne gebührengelder zusammen mit
weiteren tv und radio sendern und
zeitungen ist tele züri teil der az
medien
der aargauer medienkonzern mit 1000
mitarbeitern ist im besitz der familie
wanner peter wanner und die srg ein
angespanntes verhältnis aber die werden
natürlich mit voller macht ein
versuchter einbruch dafür sogar eine ist
fernsehen und radio es dränge aber spart
mit dass qualität der medien den
bestwert und ich bin ich der meinung das
ist ein echter gebraucht aber sich nach
dem der alte fritz groß wurde im
vergangenen jahrzehnt redimensionieren
und verschlang
aber die initiative die es zu radikal
telezüri ist teil der schweizweit
grössten gruppe private regionalsender
einige die arz rezenter erhalten auch
geld aus dem gebührentopf insgesamt sind
es 56 millionen franken
die digitalisierung ist natürlich ist es
möglich wurde privatfernsehens machen
die o spiele einfach einfach der
frequenz her das internet und um drum
glauben müssen medien ohne schafe voix
die private im wettbewerbs- oder öfter
zur eröffnung
mit der digitalisierung kam für die
printmedien die krise die neuen
konkurrenten sind vor allem ausländisch
brechen übers netz herein und heißen
facebook google youtube und co sie
liefern allerlei inhalte kostenlos
die folgen für die zeitungen sind
dramatisch abo zahlen sinken werbegelder
brechen weg im januar 2018 streiken
mitarbeitende der sca der
schweizerischen depeschenagentur gegen
eine massenentlassung der medien platz
wird zum kampfplatz alles scheint
möglich jeder mit jedem
jeder gegen jeden in wenigen monaten
haben sich hierzulande markante
veränderungen angekündigt die holding
der basler zeitung kontrolliert von svp
politiker christoph blocher schluckt den
zehnter verlag 25 gratiszeitungen mit
800.000 lesern
[Musik]
die az medien und die nzz-gruppe wollen
ihre regionalzeitungen in ein
gemeinsames unternehmen einbringen
mit 20 abozeitungen 2.000 mitarbeitern
und einem umsatz von 500 millionen
franken hatte maria gegründet 2015 die
werbe vermarktungsfirma von rené
swisscom und der srg sie weckt ängste
bei den verlierern
da sich mit sexy bus besser gemacht hat
was sie sich da beteiligt milde
politisch ist das heikel
was hatte der politik aber breite
bevölkerung für das nicht verstanden hat
dass ein vertrag ist das geschick sie
nur ein verleger ist bozen nicht vorrang
hieß es
mehrere verlegerverband betrags
beteiligen
vielleicht hätten wir gewisse dinge
anders machen können
vielleicht waren wir zu früh zu spät ich
weiß nicht aber diese idee kräfte zu
bündeln
das ist sehr schweizerisch ja es ist
wahr
dieser zusammenschluss hat große
diskussionen ausgelöst
und es ist nicht gut wenn eine firma im
kreuzfeuer der politischen diskussion
steht das ist auch nicht gut fürs
tagesgeschäft
heute zeigt sich die srg offen bei
admira neue aktionäre aufzunehmen
tamedia der größte private medienkonzern
der schweiz kündigte im dezember 2018 an
die goldbach group übernehmen zu wollen
diese verkauft fernsehwerbung von rtl
sat 1 und prosieben tamedia und die
größte vermarkterin von tv werbung
damit entsteht eine mächtige
konkurrentin zu admira
[Musik]
der vormalige srg generaldirektor roger
de weck er stand nicht nur als architekt
von admira in der kritik macht er
brachte während seiner zeit die finanzen
der srg ins lot aber er habe es verpasst
die größe der srg kritisch zu
hinterfragen sagt rainer keller damals
bei der srg zuständig für strategische
fragen wurde sport merkt was sich da tut
dokumentiert dass die kommunikation
darunter dass sich widerstand im sport
immer mehr
ja das war die sensibilität für die
pizza pizza verloren 2015 fand eine
denkwürdige volksabstimmung statt
eigentlich wurde damals nur über eine
änderung des gebührensystems entschieden
die einführung der sogenannten
haushaltsgebühr wurde nur hauchdünn
angenommen
für die srg ein schuss vor den bug
das medienhaus ag gehört den bürgerinnen
und bürgern und dass es jetzt eine
breite debatte geben wird im parlament
und in der öffentlichkeit das ist gesund
das ist wichtig das ist nötig und die
debatte wurde geführt
laut und gehässig in den monaten vor der
nobilia abstimmung sie vereinnahmte auch
die geschäftsleitung der srg
generaldirektion bei einem jahr hätte
die geschäftsleitung die liquidation des
unternehmens in die wege geleitet bei
einem nein sollte die srg neu
ausgerichtet werden
es ist ein bisschen schizophren
natürlich müssen wir unsere tägliche
arbeit korrekt erledigt aber wir müssen
uns auch darauf vorbereiten dass das
stimmvolk ja zur initiative sagen könnte
ich muss also die liquidation des
unternehmens vorbereiten
das ist sicher nicht ganz einfach aber
ich muss das mit meinem team machen
das ist klar gleichzeitig müssen wir uns
auch auf ein nein vorbereiten
wir müssen überlegen wie wir dann
weiterfahren das ist als ob wir ständig
den fokus wechseln müssten so als ob sie
mit einem fotoapparat immer wieder den
bildausschnitt wechseln würden
das ist mein leben im moment ich wechsle
die ganze zeit den fokus
sonntag vierter märz heute wird über
sein oder nichtsein der es ag
entschieden
erste resultate stimmen die beiden chefs
jean michelle china und will macht
zuversichtlich
mars heimat genf hätte es ag unerwartet
hoch die treue
egal wie der tag ausgeht eines scheint
offensichtlich demütig will sich die srg
führungsriege heute zeigen du kannst um
15 uhr kommen da werden wir alles
kommentieren
ich habe gesehen genf hat gut gestimmt
das ist aber nicht überraschend es freut
mich aber trotzdem 71,6 prozent der
abstimmenden werden am schluss die
vorlage zur abschaffung der radio und
fernsehgebühren ablehnen die spitze der
srg tritt vor die versammelte
medienschar aus dem in und ausland
interessen sehr zufrieden und sehr
erleichtert
im gleichen atemzug kündigt der chef
sparmaßnahmen für alle
unternehmenseinheiten der srg an wir
werden einen effizienzsteigerungs und
investitionsplan in der höhe von 100
millionen franken umsetzung
wir werden unser budget zu kürzen
marchand verspricht dass die srg künftig
auf unterbrecherwerbung bei spielfilmen
verzichtet und man sich im online
bereich beschränken geht ein
entgegenkommen an die verleger wie und
wo genau gespart werden soll
diese frage kann der srg generaldirektor
an diesem tag noch nicht beantworten
dies auch plan zur effizienzsteigerung
wird sich auch auf die arbeitsplätze
auswirken
ganz in der nähe im berner zunfthaus zu
schmieden
hier haben sich die befürworter der
nobilia initiative versammelt
wer die medien schaffen die ich bitte es
pc lietz sga ist nach interpret von
oliver keßler durch die spur zu
vielleicht so auch noch ein bisschen
zurück montag zunächst zu verstoßen z
der große druck trinken das ist die
größte die medienpolitische diskussion
an können so sand ist natürlich ein
küsschen zu schick da wählen werden ist
eher darum der viele viele jahre für das
projekt gesetzt und das jetzt so
natürliche ablehnung ist natürlich
stimmt trotz deutlicher
abstimmungsniederlage ist den initianten
nach feiern zumute
ihre bieridee hat in der schweiz über
monate für hitzige debatten gesorgt und
auch heute ist das interesse in und
ausländischer medien gross noch einmal
nutzen di nobile initianten die vielen
dargebotenen mikrofone zumindest
gebremst
die gerechtigkeit im medienzentrum des
bundeshauses treffen sich nach
geschlagener schlacht die akteure
vor allem die sieger des tages um
bundesrätin doris leuthard
es sah generaldirektor gilles marchand
unterhält sich mit verleger peter wanner
zwei männer deren interessen oft nicht
die gleichen sind was hält wanner von
mars versprechen die srg verändern zu
wollen
in dutzenden interviews musste der srg
generaldirektor heute erläutern wie es
mit dem grössten schweizer medienhaus
nach dieser abstimmung weitergehen soll
nun noch ein letzter tv-auftritt
wenigstens in französischer
muttersprache
es hat eine symbolische dimension wie
die schweiz heute entschieden hat es ist
eine botschaft die auch in ganz europa
gesehen wird die frage war ja in welcher
gesellschaft wollen wir leben wollen wir
in einer gesellschaft leben oder in
einem warenhaus deshalb den gericht die
entscheidung heute geht über die strg
hinaus natürlich ist sie gut für die srg
und für die privaten radio und tv
stationen
aber es geht darüber hinaus es ist eine
reflexion über unsere gesellschaft das
schweizer volk hat heute große
politische reife bewiesen
es ist auch eine entscheidung darüber
wie wir leben wollen und ich bin stolz
darauf wie die schweiz heute entschieden
hat
[Musik]
china präsentiert wurde wo honda jazz